[Music]
sorry to crush all your Titanic fan of
fiction dreams but Kate Winslet says she
and Leonardo DiCaprio were never
destined to fall in love off-screen
here's what she said on ITV's Lorraine
we were both really very young and and
luckily and this is the fortunate thing
we never fancied each other right I know
it's really annoying to hear but we
really never did and so it did mean that
we were just able to have this you know
pounds yeah and I'm able to eat tease
each other in which we still do and you
know so it's it's really very strong
strong friendship yes yes the friendship
is alive and well 20 years later you're
gonna do something with her again coming
up soon
I'd love to there's there she's my
favorite actress in the industry and
Kate recently reminisced with et about
filming Titanic with Leo all those years
ago we did have such a laugh really we
did and just the friendship I think that
we had and yeah I do have really really
fond memories of the two of us you know
getting through it and laughing and and
then keeping each other very yeah
[Music]
you